hello and to welcome to this video
playing a set 79 he wasn't a four-player
back then maybe yes he has changed
changed his repertoire okay now he goes
back to some e for based opening it's
something funny come on okay
at least it's something interesting
something creative I have no idea if
it's any good but it it's probably a
position that never never has been
played after move 6 being on virgin
territory okay so he doesn't mind the
opening of the age farm you know so what
now probably t6 so how do i use this age
file Bishop d7 Queen c8 Bishop Adrian
playing in the absolute caveman style
yeah probably Bishop age 3 immediately
it can take n play kingi to that doesn't
help yes possibly d5 but what can I do
it's not so bad
okay here i want to go to g form that
can not be bad I think
now it looks good action Knight to g4
maybe I get into entry seven and
canceling no NaCI for in itself is so
annoying don't really know what is
replies okay takes that I can tick with
the night I'm not sure that it is
helpful but not probably not probably
not helpful if we place Bishop g5 now I
am Bishop g4 and two centers totally
falling apart isn't that good let's
think for a moment him night the center
is falling apart
you
Bishop f3 I probably have bishop age 32
minutes up on the clock that's unheard
of my looks it looks pretty awful
why
you have a simple idea is to take the
form and term it's really not Tori not
clear what is replies yeah even here I
can just take stuff by taking f3 taking
the form which is not bad really non
let's do it come on let's play in a
simple fashion wind stuff and be happy
with it I also have this huge time edge
I check
check
b2 hangs this is why I'm not playing
their signs yeah it was a I really think
that maybe 992 age 5 is dangerous it
really is I think he has to react
somehow and somehow he didn't react at
all maybe you should play age phone I
don't don't know this districts it looks
uncomfortable already a little bit a
castling is definitely risky could have
taken with the f porn but it's also not
something you are so happy about i mean
i have easy ideas like this and also
just play the dead caveman attack bishop
out 27 Bishop e3 i it's it's not nice it
really isn't after f4 and winning him
now yes civil 92 or creed III something
like that here the computer already
indicates a loss as nigel is so so awful
to meet you know lagi force also good
but yeah he is losing minus two it's
pretty drastic ed for immediately also
was strong but here I'm also winning the
house threatening those discoveries
threatening 9527 Chan yeah I think he
had to react to that age five move
probably by going age for himself it was
a very risky to allow me playing age for
okay thanks for watching